ألغت لجنة من خبراء الصحة
التوصيات السابقة بشأن
فحوصات سرطان البروستاتا ، تشير
الإرشادات الجديدة المنشورة في مجلة
الجمعية الطبية الأمريكية إلى أن
الرجال الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 55 و 69 عامًا
يجرون محادثة شاملة مع أطبائهم
حول إيجابيات وسلبيات
فحوصات سرطان البروستاتا  خاصة إذا كانوا
معرضين لخطر كبير للإصابة بالمرض ،
فهذا تحديث للإرشادات السابقة الصادرة
في عام 2012 والتي نصحت بعدم
إجراء فحوصات روتينية بسبب المخاطر المرتبطة
بالعلاج الإضافي ، يمكن أن تؤدي الإيجابيات الكاذبة
إلى مزيد من الاختبارات والعلاج
التي يمكن أن تسبب سلس البول وتوجيه
I  قد يكون هناك خلل وظيفي ، لكن الأبحاث الجديدة تظهر أن
فحوصات مستضد البروستاتا المحدد
أو PSA يمكن أن تمنع بالفعل
المزيد من حالات السرطان أكثر مما كان
يعتقد سابقًا بالنسبة لأولئك الرجال الذين لا
يعانون من أعراض سرطان البروستاتا ،
والتحدث إلى طبيبك حول إجراء الفحوصات
كل سنتين إلى أربع سنوات يعد أمرًا مثاليًا
وفقًا لفريق الخدمات
الوقائية الأمريكية الخاص بسرطان البروستاتا  er هو أحد
أكثر أنواع السرطان شيوعًا بين الرجال في المرتبة الثانية
بعد سرطان الجلد ، ولدى الرجال في الولايات المتحدة فرصة 13
٪ لتطويره على مدار
حياتهم في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم
أنا Kim Hutcherson